This pinwheel pillow is a quick,
make it in a weekend fun project.
Make yours special with variegated yarns
stripes or alternate solid colors in each
section.
Embellish with flowers
embroidery or add a button.
Mine is knit in plain stockinette, but you
could use any stitch pattern, even lace.
We'll use the Knit it Now
Circle calculator tools so that you
can use any yarn and there's no math.
Believe it or not, this pillow cover
is knit in one piece using short rows.
The selvage edges of the knitting will be
folded around the pillow and they'll be
joined to create the center front
and the center back of the pillow.
I chose to knit six wedges.
Now I'm entering my gauge and I'm covering
an inexpensive 16 inch pillow form.
I want mine to fit snugly, so I'm going
to knit my piece to 15 inch diameter.
When I generate my pattern, I'll
get two sets of instructions.
At the top is the abbreviated version two
needles and hold three times one needle
and hold 31 times and below
are row by row instructions.
In case I get distracted while I'm
knitting, I can always look at my row
counter and know where I am.
Start your knitting with
waste yarn and ravel cord.
Now, if you like to use a cast on comb
when you cast on, that's fine for getting
started.
But you're going to need to remove it
because it's going to get in the way for
this project.
To create the pinwheel shapes.
We're going to short row as instructed
in the pattern, creating more rows of
knitting in the middle of the piece.
This area will be the
outside edge of the pillow.
You need to be comfortable with putting
needles and your carriage into hold.
And if you're unsure about
this, check your machine manual.
I'm starting by putting two stitches
opposite the carriage into hold position.
When I knit across, I'll manually wrap
that first needle in hold to prevent a
hole.
Now for a decorative effect.
Don't wrap and embrace the
eyelets that are formed.
Could allow a contrast in color of fabric
to peek through your pillow cover, or you
could thread a ribbon or a
cord through the eyelets.
Now, I don't want holes, so
I'm going to wrap every row.
Notice how I'm moving weights towards the
center of the work as I knit to prevent
stitches from dropping off.
When you get down to the last center
stitch, be sure and wrap and put the
needles opposite the carriage
into work and knit across.
Then put the remaining needles
and work and knit across again.
You've completed the first
wedge of your pillow,
I'm going to start all over and
create the rest of the wedges.
The piece is going to look really, really
odd at this point, but hang in there.
It's going to be beautiful
when you're done knitting, scrap off.
Now, even if you don't normally bind off
your scrap, I suggest you bind off for
this project.
You're going to be stuffing that pillow
form into your knitting and then working a
seam binding off skin
to prevent a disaster.
Don't ask, just learn from
my mistake and bind off.
Fold the knitting in half, and now
you can start seeing that shape.
You might want to block
at this point or not.
Insert the pillow form and
carefully Kitchener stitch.
The opening closed.
Done neatly, you'll never see the seam.
You'll want to secure the centers of the
pillow with a running stitch and gather up
that hole, embellish it,
put on a button, whatever.
Voila, you have a quick fun pillow that
can be a canvas for your creativity.